yell her out
tell tony tim i won't be coming home
this christmas
tell scarlet i do give it him
pardon me okay so raised by wolves is
steamrolling ahead on hbo max
and we're already at the sixth and
seventh episode throughout this video
we're going to be breaking down the
storyline of the show
and giving our thoughts and theories on
what could be going on
obviously there will be heavy spoilers
here so if you haven't had a chance to
check out the entries yet then i highly
recommend that you turn off now
make sure you subscribe to the channel
for breakdowns of the full season
and please drop a thumbs up if you enjoy
the video without the way
thank you for clicking this now let's
get into race by wolves
okay so i got a couple of comments last
time saying not just to do a
straightforward recap
as it's boring so we're gonna be going
through the main points of the episodes
and sort of tying them all together
hopefully into one cohesive video for
you guys
bloody love no promises though now we
open with mother recounting her memories
with champion
and the sixth entry centers around their
relationship
it's clear that the pale loved one
another and if you watched our video
last week then you'll know he theorized
that campion was the mysterious figure
that lived on the planet
since dropping that breakdown i've
thought into it a lot deeper
and no i don't think it's champion per
se i do believe that his consciousness
has been transferred into a machine we
saw that he was able to program a life
like baby
and if he can do this it makes sense
that he could also build a replacement
body
we know that this figure doesn't move
like a human but it is indeed in human
form
it's also able to trace tracking devices
and clearly it's been caring for tally
so it is still in line with the mission
that mother has
now potentially father or tally has
drawn an image of mother and champion
kissing
neither were there when this happened
but the fact that they've been able to
replicate this
shows that it's likely been told to them
through champion
champion could have uploaded it further
and wiped his memory
or what's more likely is that he told
tally who then did it
champion also exists in the simulation
and says that he has many things
so there are hints towards it now i
think that the character is there
just hanging back to not interfere but
he will be there should it come down to
it
either way mother sort of sort of cheats
on father it is a cheating
i don't know and she spends a lot of
time with him in the simulation
recalling her past and also fantasizing
about their life together
this is sort of robbed from her in this
entry i think out of the season so far
six is the best episode in the run on
the outskirts of the camp we see as
marcus in the mid-three
stalk the location looking for an
opening marcus ensued debate over
whether to tell paul the truth about his
parents
and you very much get the idea that
there's this sort of surrogacy that
exists on the planet
both mother and father are of course not
the parents of the children
but they're raising them and this is of
course mirrored in the mithraic pair
i don't know why in fiction orphans are
pretty much always used as main
characters
but almost every big franchise that i
can think of
deals with at least one character that
doesn't know their true parents
that's the sound of a hundred movies
being listed in the comment section
no but when asked why so few disney
movies have mothers in them
don horn a producer of the studio said
one reason is it's practical
because the movies are 80 to 90 minutes
long and disney films are about growing
up
they're about that day in your life when
you have to accept responsibility
in shorthand it's much quicker to have
characters grow up when you bump
up their parents bambi's mother gets
killed so he has to grow up
belle only has a father but he gets lost
so she has to step into that position
and it's very much story shorthand i
think this is
also the case in race by wolves with the
characters pretty much having to raise
themselves
as let's face it mother and father
though almost there
don't fully know what it means to be
human mirroring this the mithraic are
too far into their religion to
to properly raise the kids i feel and
yeah there is very much a feeling that
they're gonna have to do it on their own
now we learn that tally has been
entering the camp and leaving her dolls
behind
tempest is also haunted by what happened
to her but she promises that she won't
end her or the baby's life
there's a discussion of dreams and
timbers asks mother if she has them
she denies it but we know that the
simulation in some ways
has been providing a dreamlike world for
her to escape to
it's almost like an addiction for her
and ultimately leads to her downfall
paul and campion also start to move in
opposite directions
and though initially it seems like
they're happy to allow the other to have
their own opinion
this ultimately turns out to cause
divisions it's rare that people can
actually debate on certain aspects of
life without things elevating
and the internet twitter especially is a
good example of that
now paul is clearly more adept to
survive on the planet as champion won't
make the tough choices
and thus he lashes out at him i want
them to be brothers so much
but in the back of my mind the story of
romulus and remus is always there
and we know that only goes one way with
the death of one of them by the others
hand
paul embarrasses campion by completing a
puzzle faster than he did
and we see how fractured the latter's
ego becomes he was of course the top dog
at the camp after being the only
survivor
but he's slowly starting to see that
he's not as special as he thinks
now to be fair to him we did learn that
when the kids were in hibernation
their minds continued whilst their
bodies were frozen and thus paul is
actually a lot older mentally than he
appears
the mithraic really step into their own
under marcus's rule
and we see how they operate after
trimming the fat of the elders
they cunningly stalk mother and they
must have been watching our video last
week because
they take the plan of waiting until
she's plugged in to strike
hey what a rascal that marcus is now can
being a mother get it on
and they're flying without wings but
she's sadly
shot through the heart and you're to
blame because you give love a bad name
now
now she sees a strange vision of the
milk falling
which for her symbolizes death and then
a vast dark blanket comes over the
planet
there's clearly something on the planet
feeding people with visions
and throughout both entries it gets more
and more prevalent
the show could be saying that something
spiritual exists on kepler
all perhaps everyone is a machine and
they just don't know it i doubt
i doubt that's the case but marcus of
course spent a long time in hibernation
and we also know that memories can be
uploaded who knows
this might all just be one big
simulation and that's how reality is
able to bend
it could be the food making people
hallucinate or perhaps even the planet's
original
inhabitants but yeah drop your theories
below on what you think it is
anyway they fail to destroy mother and
she transforms before unleashing hell
marcus also refers to sue as mary which
was her
original name and this is a nice little
nod to the last episode as he refused to
call her that
subtly showing that he was acknowledging
their new lives over their old
the methodics stormed the camp and badly
damaged father
and i love that we finally got some more
action in the series
the first episode had an absolutely
stellar scene for its ending climax
and here it's just as tense mother
arrives and saves father
and i'm not gonna lie it almost it
almost had me i thought
i thought we were gonna lose him now on
the outskirts of the camp
marcus comes across sue and paul and he
uses ball as a tool to take mother's
eyes
sue is clearly against this and her
motherly instinct kicks in
whereas i think mark has come to the
realization that he isn't their son
marcus axes mother through the chest
like jack in the shining did to dick
and just as he's about to kill her he
hears an almost
alien voice that tells him to stop
marcus is slowly starting to interpret
these as the voice of soul
but if my theory is correct this is
champion who's slowly manipulating
everyone
we learn that mother isn't breaking down
anything even though it seems like she
has been at points
and perhaps both the machines and humans
are being placed on a path that will
eventually make them realize
that they have to coexist with one
another whatever's going on in the
shadows i do feel like it's all coming
together as part of a master plan
and yeah lots of lots of things could be
going on now champion 2 is guided by a
mysterious voice
and this could be the creator using
technology to reach out to those on the
planet
or it may be something more supernatural
the thing with raised by wolves is
that there really are the two arguments
of science versus religion going on
and even when watching the series we as
viewers have to question what's really
happening
we still don't know for definite but i
loved seeing the strong atheist marcus
slowly start to question his beliefs
there's definitely an interconnecting
tissue between the two sides
and we see it switching him when he
notices the scalpel from his stream in
mother's possession
anyway they take her captive stringing
her up in an almost crucifixion-like
pose
jesus was of course wrongly pinned to
the cross and he ended up going on to be
humanity's savior
so the show could potentially be setting
this up as a plot motif
in later episodes now the snake skeleton
also takes some focus through this
episode
though we haven't seen one of these
creatures alive yet father did find some
skin shed from one earlier in the season
and it is possible that they were behind
the creation of the big pits on the
planet
i would love to see one pop up and
invade the camp as in order to have shed
so recently
they would have had to have been alive
now mother reveals that she knows marcus
is not only an atheist
but he's also going under a new identity
mother of course mimicked his appearance
in the first episode
and it's likely that this scan showed
her the surgical scores and tattoos that
he had
she sees kinship between the pair and we
learn that this is why she spared him
now in the camp children become divided
over whether to help champion or not
the adults at the location state that he
must be baptized
as he's unpure they want him to conform
but most of the children
already know that he's a good kid and
they class him as one of them
i think this really speaks to how
prejudices are often passed on from
adults to children
and if we have the wrong role models
then they can inflict people with
several things
that make them hate others for stupid
reasons such as faith or race
their faith is clearly being tested i
think that many of the children
actually prefer their life in the camp
over what they had with the church
this is especially evident in tempest
who as we know was subjected to abuse
the church want to basically reprogram
campion to fall in line with them and
this is muradin father who is completely
changed personality wise
i do think the dad we know and love will
come back but there's a lot of avenues
the show could go
now another interesting aspect is that
the mithraic pretty much invade the camp
and begin to build their own i think
this is a metaphor for native americans
and the european invaders that traveled
to the country and ousted the people
that lived there
in the first episode the narrator said
that they were often referred to as
pioneers
which is also something that the
europeans were referred to when they
started to move across the country
i still believe that the radioactive
food will be used as a weapon
similar to the blankets laced with small
pox and there's definitely a lot going
on
the champion almost gets baptized but he
is very much forced into it
in the ritual he realizes that the
headstones of his siblings
have been used as furniture and this
makes him reject the methodic
we really see another side to them in
the seventh episode with the group
referring to the atheists as solas
however sue is clearly the only one with
any morals
and we watch as marcus slips deeper into
the religion
i love their interactions and we
ultimately witness through sui's eyes
how power corrupts
sue is of course an atheist herself and
she wants to save champion and deliver
him away from the church
and the life that she's found herself
trapped in sue suggests destroying
mother
so that the mithrae cannot reprogram her
and use her as a weapon
marcus takes mother who tries to snitch
on him but it falls on deaf ears
they take her into the woods and there's
actually a trail of milk left behind
which allows tempest to follow them the
creatures on the planet to appear
i think they will probably pop up next
time and try to invite the camp
now mother reaches out to father and try
just change back just please change back
though it seems like he's not listening
he actually saves her life
and leaves a rope which allows her to
climb out the real father is likely
still in there
and she was able to reach out to him i
think appealing to his subconsciousness
the marcus also comes face to face with
a vision of his old self
and he battles it out with him we see
that this actually
isn't there and it's all in his head the
older version wins
which also perhaps showcases that the
character is wrestling with his identity
again i think that campion is actually
feeding everyone's visions
in order to protect not only mother but
also the children of the camp
someone is likely spying on them as
paul's mouses all to return to him
after falling down one of the pits this
is near to where paul spotted tally
so it could have been her who brought
the mouse back as we know she's been
visiting the camp
marcus returns all cut up from the
battle with himself
and states that he is the child from the
prophecy which ends the episode
now is this the truth or is it simply
delusions of grandeur
well i'm still in two minds about it i
think that marcus is slowly going off
the deep end
and that he started to believe that he's
the one named in the prophecy that will
start a new civilization
however i still think that this could be
false and that we will see the character
believing this
actually lead to his downfall there was
of course the narration at the start of
episode 1
which sounded like it was coming from a
teenage boy so i still think that paul
and champion are the more likely options
marcus is also slowly using paul more
and more seeing him less as a person and
more as a follower
which i don't think that someone would
do if if they were the chosen one it
just seems weird
we're also episode 7 and there's still
three entries left
so i do think there's enough time to do
this and and really pull the rug out
from under his feet
this would crush him and it would also
allow there to be a misdirect
to to go back to the the pretty obvious
cliched thing
however all that could still be wrong
and you know what
he might be the chosen one i don't know
what i do know though
is that the show doesn't ever really
deal in complete absolutes
and i can even see ending with us being
able to interpret it as either
confirming the religious aspects of the
show
or not perhaps it will end up with this
making our own minds up on who the true
one is
as it really could go either way who
knows maybe maybe the planet just has a
funny gas in its atmosphere
that makes people hallucinate i don't
know but what i would like to hear
is your thoughts and theories so make
sure you comment below and let me know
if you enjoyed this video then please
drop a thumbs up and make sure you check
out our breakdown of the other episodes
in the series which are going to be
linked at the end
we're also giving away a free copy of
the christopher nolan collection
and all you have to do to be on the
chance of winning is like the video
subscribe to the channel and drop a
comment below
the winner is going to be chosen at
random at the end of the month so make
sure you get involved
if you want to support the channel and
get to see content early then please
consider clicking the join button below
you can also come chatters on the
discord server linked in the description
or heavy spoilers on twitter thanks for
making it until the end of the video
you being the best i've been definition
and i'll see you next time
take care peace
[Music]
foreign